le premier usage c'est serre arman
spécialiste de mouvements ouvriers qui
étaient à trop de crise du britannique
qui était lui même trop de pistes et qui
avait écrit un livre s'appelle le
prophète et le prolétariat en 94 et à ce
moment-là il envisagé mais pas forcément
de façon toujours à probati ve la
possibilité d'une alliance entre
l'islamisme définit d'ailleurs assez
différemment de la façon dont nous
entendons aujourd'hui et et puis là
l'ultra gauche entre ou l'extrême gauche
7 cette alliance le le titre encore une
fois dû livrer le prophète et le
prolétariat autrement dit c'était l'idée
qu'il pouvait y avoir comme ça a déjà
été dit il ya un instant il peut y avoir
dans la manche et les musulmans une
possibilité de trouver un nouveau
prolétariat capable de faire alliance
donc et de renverser l'ordre établi
puisqu'il des trotskistes maintenant il
était aussi extrêmement anti-religieux
d'ailleurs pas illogique en tentant de
pister
il était assez critique par rapport à la
façon dont l'islamiste comporter là où
il pouvait avoir le pouvoir
ceci étant évidemment il ne parlait pas
d'islamisme au sens de terrorisme nous
en parlons aujourd'hui et le mot
islamo-gauchiste il avait un doublement
à défaut fondamental enfin il y en a
beaucoup mais à défaut fondamental c'est
que quand on sait pas si on parle de
l'islam si on parle de l'islamisme et le
problème est que précisément chez ceux
qui l'utilisent il ya la volonté de
confusion c'est à dire au fond de dire
qu'un musulman et potentiellement à
l'islamiste écoles islamistes me c'est
au fond à djihadistes 1a terroristes et
c'est ce que blanc caire disait ouf on
en attaquant les intellectuels
responsables de dévoyer en quelque sorte
leur leurs fonctions en se faisant les
propagandistes d'une idéologie
totalement quand qui conduirait les
l'université le mot degrés
a été repris d'ailleurs par vidal qui à
l'époque d'ailleurs quand blanc qu'elle
avait utilisé le premier avait voulu
défendre l'honneur universités elle a un
peu oublié ce qu'était l'université
aujourd'hui
[Musique]